three two one action hey guys welcome
back to off the record we retire whoa
[ __ ] we want because it's a crew
takeover kind of day over and look at
Devon shirt because Devin so proudly
wanted to eat you changes just food if
you really want to know it's another day
you guys we're doing multiple of these
right right I just wanted to wear this I
just wear those same whole I enjoyed
every day strange things three Cosmo
thanks
you know if you feel like you're in
Hawaii then you are in Hawaii you're
like I do like Seattle though like
genuinely like so yeah yeah it was great
but today we have pack on room the
entire day today Pat is our I guess like
cameraman editor a little bit everything
to yes he's our singer slinger doesn't
talk much but what he does [ __ ] go
like it's the best whenever he's on
camera for party and he says something
and all of us over the headsets the crew
just go like we're all just like
reacting to it yeah but usually a lot of
times people like totally miss it on
camera which is [ __ ] hilarious an ass
is fine it makes it that much better or
sometimes my favorite part is when
you'll mutter something thinking that
nobody else could hear it and then you
like because when you mutter you like
look down you like and then you like
look up and you see me like sometimes
Kyle will be like booming something
India there you mutter something you
could just be like I can hear that
no runs away like beating Yoshi and
ninja singers classic so if you guys
haven't checked out JK party going over
and take a look and look at the videos
at Pat's in because I can almost
guarantee you that every video he is in
there's at least one line gold pure gold
attention let's talk about something
else we talked about whatever one video
is kind of like focused around you at
least I guess you see work for you you
do Joe's like blog and stuff to write
like you so you edit and shoot video for
him yeah and shoot video for jiggy party
and yeah and then outside of KK I also
do things for a non-profit I suppose
then also do like like freelance stuff
like I'm one else in this company to I
think they all have like work within JK
and we also have like one like side
thing to know or multiple what's your
just throws out there well I just like
well I did you really just say that
what's your um what's your like idea cuz
everyone I think has a bunch of stuff
that they do but what's the thing that
you want to get into the most like for
me it's like camera work for like Nelson
it's editing yeah I think one of my
things was to get more into like cameras
done category yeah but like honestly
like within like the past few years I
kind of wasn't like really pay attention
to that stuff so and that's probably
because like we were just like within
like the JK circle right right we were
just doing like that eating news and
yeah doing party and there's already
like a were a certain workflow do but
yeah those things so we didn't get to do
anything like creative atmosphere I'm
trying to take like more of a step to be
more creative yeah about a lot of camera
gear recently today which I might or
nice might or might not have encouraged
you to do we're going to even earlier
today like Ryan was like Pat convinced
you not to buy another backpack I'm like
you came to me don't you do buy that
backpack
it's true don't don't buy it on the
backpack no no don't do it don't do it
you're gonna end up with a bunch of like
a box oh no too many backpacks I know
that struggle right yeah it's it's a
very common struggle amongst backpacker
aficionados it's just like do I buy this
other backpack people that have too many
bags yeah yeah yeah awesome
weights are you like more like like what
what type of filmmaking interesting is
your are you more of like music video
narrative or don't kind of figure it out
yeah cuz like I'm just kind of getting
into like everything so like right now
like one of my side things are weddings
right and then also real estate real
estate is like we just really random
yeah back to kind of boring it's really
just like setting up it's a sixth aging
more right he's gotta fill in like the
void spaces but then like the room and
then this is really just slap it on a
gimbal
mmm super pretty yeah yeah your modular
skills have gotten really good like I
remember when you first started working
like the seeing some of your first edits
and seeing them now like your your skill
with montage is really good and I think
way you shoot
it's very montage heavy and montage
based so yeah I feel like that at least
as far as your skill set has come like
it come a long way since they first
started yeah yeah I was kind of funny to
the other day I was talking to Nelson
uh-huh not buff Nelson my Nelson is okay
yeah I was talking to Nelson and then we
did like a film festival with a few of
us um last year and that was kind of
like the DP kind of came up ready for
that day yeah I said something really
does like I don't know why people buy
like different lenses stuff I like
there's one lens it has like all the
focal lengths everything like no that's
not how that stuff some people do though
some people make it work yeah but yeah
then getting more into like buying like
lenses and like paying attention to what
things do right yeah it's like when you
started he didn't he was like just have
two lenses like I love robbery guys when
I started out because he was so into
just not being about the man or the
studio so I just got do yourself the
everyt was it rebel will even call rebel
without a cause
cameras might never
without McCree that's what it was yeah
yeah I was so so that's why I loved
YouTube in particular and move over each
other like I like the idea of not giving
a [ __ ] about the big ass studio oh yeah
totally I think and I think it depends
on what you're shooting to because it's
like for YouTube stuff I think we all
have discovered this over time is that
like you can spend a lot of money trying
to make it nicer and everybody hates it
everybody [ __ ] hates it so we'll just
care honestly about the type of content
they don't care about like yeah we're
but it's weird like YouTube is one of
the few spaces where you can invest more
money and time and people will have an
adverse reaction to it like people go
the opposite direction it's not just a
matter of like people won't care people
will actively hate it for being nicer
which is bizarre like an unfamiliar it's
almost like um a set of some sort it's
like yeah so but it's like with this
last danger Boise thing we shot
everything on I think just yeah
ninety-nine ninety-eight percent of the
movie we are part of the shove the short
pilot we shot on just a cannon 24 to 105
and so example with that like you can do
a lot with like one or two lenses
especially if they're zooms you're
especially give you know different
publicity it doesn't fit everything like
I won't try and be out here pretending
like this is the only thing you need but
you know for a lot of the times like you
know you can you can use it and get away
with a lot it's the purpose though cuz
like yeah we're doing it like we're
doing a mockumentary so if you did that
like zooming things but if you were
trying to do something more cinematic
yeah yeah exactly
it all depends on what you're going from
what you're looking for and what you
think can get away with
knowing that too but it's like also in
terms of the actual visual language of
your style
luhan's is yes are great when you're
playing with them it's a great toy but
lighting out rules oh yeah lighting
makes you know the nicest lens in the
world and you have no lights and you
have no picture
I forgot the guy's name his name is Stu
something a very famous like indie
filmmaker guy he was saying that like he
would be on film says just take his like
little dvx mm-hm just to put it in the
scene he's like oh this makes my dvx
look like a freaking cinema camera
because it's not yeah like you're saying
it's always about lighting I'm really
about your camera sometimes people ask
that - like what camera should I get
worth what editing software should I get
I fired on Windows Movie Maker when I
was editing
you literally can just use it you'll
naturally grow out of yeah those pings
so once you start with those entry-level
free things and then you're like oh but
I wish I could do this right and you
start doing miss things out of this
suite and you're just like oh yeah I
guess I need this now and I'm like oh
okay now look it's a premiere oh now I
look into life it's almost worse to
start off with a really a complex
editing suite it's just too much doing
yeah and that was the nice thing I
started with Windows Movie Maker and
then I got Sony Vegas because it was
like oh my god we had the same path okay
I've hired it yeah exactly
or I hired it but I got it related to
the early days I got a really cheap
copying yeah yeah it must be nice to be
rich Ryan yeah I read everything up
until like maybe four years ago Adobe
don't don't send him to collection but
yeah like so then and then what I liked
about Sony Vegas was that it gave you
like a step if you had a question about
something you'd have a little help
bubble and I would actually like guide
your cursor over and show you where
everything was and that was really cool
and then I just moved to Adobe because I
realized that a lot of other gigs and
stuff like for this job and stuff people
were using Adobe and Adobe had a nice
student subscription for you it's like
I'm still really inexpensive and you get
the full suite of stuff and I don't have
to worry about pirating or
incompatibility because of that so
that's why I moved on to that but yeah I
think it's almost detrimental to start
with like oh like Adobe because an hour
am i doing yeah because you as a
profession I don't know where to use I
use avid if you step into avid you would
be like I'm don't touch avid twice I was
like why do they do this it's the
industry standard it's built for those
old hats so like it was when they were
trying to convert them from film like
actual cutting of film like hey don't
use this computer please so it's built
for those guys yeah yeah it's starting
to get a little bit better now where
it's starting to evolve to like our
generation so it's like hey key please
use ours now cuz these guys are going to
die off soon Final Cut was the more it
was it was until oh okay behind that one
yeah so what was it that tin came out
was five years ago so my thing like that
yeah I was about when I finished up at
college a year before that I got
certified in Final Cut 7 which was the
one that was like Leica v1 yeah it was
it was compete about to compete with
Abbott and like the pro thing and I was
I was there for a class but like I think
six months survived seven got my
certification like few months later
we're announcing photo could teen it is
completely different it's iMovie Pro I
was like what alpha I was so mad before
I went back because I heard that like
that drove a lot of the other like
professional editors away for that
they're just like Oh [ __ ] Walter March
the guy had made a blink blink an eye
he's a very famous editor who was like
Hannukah Hannukah
even though era i was like no avid's the
things like no punic that's like great
completely like the way I'm out wait now
he's premiere no he's premiere now
that's the cool thing about Adobe sorry
for all the editing talk this is really
interesting
another cool thing about premiere is
that I find that they're key mappings
and stuff they can map everything out
just like final cutter for all the other
they have presets for avid or whoever is
using whatever cuz they're real smart
with like trying to bring people into
their suite with like hey look you're
all controls can be the same you know
the program itself is different but look
it like dynamic links with other Adobe
programs and stuff so that's why I like
Adobe but I know I know why a lot of
people use avid and I get it just not
for me ya know that's my first time I'm
hearing about evidence I've no idea
about avid in college because then all
the professors are like your film you're
going to use average average the
industry standard it still is the case
though if you are trying to get so for
new media you're gonna be premier even
some you know more traditional you got
from here but if you're trying to really
get paid on like a lot of relational
stuff yeah you want a bit if you want to
really make as I get it it's just not
for me yeah you know what I don't think
it will be for me forever but also you
don't really intend it yeah I'm not I
really am NOT an editor and nor do I
like really kind of claim to be yeah
yeah so yeah sure I mean it's not
sponsorship right out the window on it
UI is so not intuitive to me I know that
there's people who've used for years but
just yeah
so I probably get soggy areas like what
yeah I'm kind of lost just because I
completely studying something different
like a different medium yeah so like we
don't even
have it the only thing that we're like
close to is probably Adobe things all
these Adobe like Photoshop Illustrator
premier what is the next animation like
industry standard layer program for like
Conejo honestly you're asking the wrong
person because the Longbeach animation
program at least at the time that i went
in was only great for 2d animation and
they're trying to make their way into
three dimensions so honestly I don't
really remember a lot of um editing
software front of it I mean like I think
two boom is one of them - yeah - boom
was one of them where it's just like you
take photos of like all the drawings
that you do and then you time it out oh
I know that
I see Aki all the time her her friend is
also in animation and she's always on
her Wacom like huge Wacom tablet and
like drawing stuff out and stuff but
don't know what program to use for that
so yeah I mean uh I think I think every
company is different
great right but I mean like 3d like some
people might use my or some other
program which I don't know like a
problem Maya I only know what what I
just touched in college right yeah I
think for Aki I think she does stuff on
Photoshop mmm yeah because you could
animate on Photoshop but really I don't
know that but you could yeah there's a
sequencing I used to that for like four
lightsabers before I gods effects which
again is that for progress thing yes yes
so basically you know 24 frames in a
second so what you do is essentially
just draw it out every freaking frame
now as it makes a little easier cuz you
can use keyframes you say like sounds
like the word saber to be here
saber can be here well I do is animate
this one in this one and you know I do
the animation like okay that was a
little you put it right here
why use your graphics move back in the
day I was like paint would you'd watch
it like you look like you get that like
Adobe Flash was also their way of what
it was over once
goodbye photos wasn't that great it
wasn't that great I use flash in college
yeah for a little bit is the lights a
bring your first like pitot fixed I
guess so yeah yeah I guess so what got
me cuz the first thing I did I was doing
a video for my dad like home video about
like baseball I think my will so there's
baseball game some like that and I was
like oh cool it's fine that I could like
take different clips and put them
together and there makes like a thing
like a sequence yeah and then just like
think of all the possibilities I could
get real nerdy with him to make his
channel definitely like succeeded in a
lot of ways it is funny because it fits
you so well I'm kind of curious for all
of you guys what made you interested in
studying in film oh yeah yeah yeah I've
always been more practical with I never
have been like you me when I start going
to film school I actually realized that
I'm not a film guy at all
because those conversations that people
would have and like you know being on
nerdy about like oh like shut the [ __ ]
up I just like [ __ ] make a gene
that's a good way to approach it though
I feel like too many people get caught
up in the myopathy of life of like
looking at like you know film directors
I I do this too sometimes but it's like
after a certain point it's like a lot of
those people don't create anything
talking about it but they don't do any
like actual makeup from cause she was
like that he always would talk to me and
be like oh man you're just like a
producer I'm not like he was way more
like I guess more eloquent about you
have the way talk about film like he
could be like a film theorist or like
that but practically he never actually
put into pressure those people go into
teaching they go into reviewing they're
doing a lot of things but not
necessarily like making things that's
why I love Robert Rodriguez cuz he was
such a doer
like he wasn't like a oh I'm gonna cheat
you I do listen we're talking about the
the you know whatever about Martin
Scorsese's films or Casablanca
although he liked those some of us be
like I like Casablanca actually I like
this again so glad I was supposed to
some of those things but yeah just hate
talking both totally yeah feeling this
very much you too
I feel like it's you to a college like
you you do get really into the theory of
a lot of stuff but I feel like at the
end of the day you're just go make
something
Yoko drove me crazy yeah yeah because it
drove me like mildly crazy so for you I
can imagine you're just because I got
you in film yeah
um I don't know it's weird cuz I
actually like ever since I was a little
kid I always wanted a camera like to go
shoot stuff I remember I was like four
and like my family and like family
friends were all happy like this yard
sells somebody had like a really old a
huge VHS camera there sounds like five
bucks was like yeah she's like no Deb
and it's broken my fix it's like no go
play with your toys okay Devon if
there's an interaction that I've heard
that's more Devon than that what about
you Sean um I always enjoyed making like
you know how in middle school and high
school they make you do the video
projects mm-hmm I always really enjoyed
making those video projects uh I started
with Windows Movie Maker yeah you know
made a video and realized it took like a
day to export on my really shitty laughs
all day and then you would export it and
then they'd be like no sound reason
you're some [ __ ] like that it was the
worst and you have to do it again like
one of them I specifically remember this
moment of I had tested the DVD in like a
bunch of DVD players in my house brought
it to class and didn't work yeah all
only the video played nice none of the
sound played and it was embarrassed I
still got a thing on YouTube it's like
you should have tested it on DVD players
I still did get an a on that project
that's what's wrong with our schooling
system you just get participation DVD
player and everything yeah that's how I
got my start and then I would do really
dumb things like back in the day I
remember I made a maplestory music video
yes way back in it like that's that's an
old-school [ __ ] I do Mable sort of I
made anime music videos Naruto and
that's how I would get like the basics
of how to edit and everything and and
how did like timing and relearn exactly
like you'd go to the B and yeah and it's
just all those little things that
eventually like compiled and then when I
got to high school I saw that they had a
video program and I was like I really
want to be in this video program and so
junior and senior I joined and I was in
it and it's basically the same as what
we're doing now just making really dumb
videos you know for the campus to see
and that [ __ ] was so much so much fun I
made it back when I had my really long
Bowl cut hair mm-hmm we all do and throw
it in the throne in this edit I'm like a
combination between like Devin and Sean
I think like when I was like little I
would do like these like a little like
some things I guess now I just like
realize now - huh it's like for example
I think in the third grade we had like
this uh like assembly right right and we
had one word it's called like the
imagination machine okay please have
that No
so basically like we all like wrote
scripts and stuff and we submitted it to
them oh that's cool and then they came
to our school and they like performed it
oh oh like I remember like riding mines
but then I remember getting called in
there like oh yeah yours got chosen and
then I was like II was like really cool
because then you like saw your scripts
like come to life right right and then
like I was I was like cheering you on
and stuff and like I still have my
certificate Wow from like you've run it
I'm going to
that's what got him started do ya and
then in high school I also wanted to
join like the video class and kind of
thing and then I went to the professor
and I was like heard the teacher he's
not professor I want to teach her and I
was like hey so uh what do you think of
a me going into actual like the film
industry as like a career he's like it's
like well my friend works with Michael
Bay and I became a teacher so really
that environment explains your
personality so much that things just
like well he's successful and look at me
dude what about you Ryan
for me it's funny in eighth grade I had
to do a career project I had to choose
and we had to choose a career they
didn't even have to be like they're like
oh this probably would be the career
that you stick with but just choose
something so you can do this project so
I'm alright cool so I chose I chose film
because I was like [ __ ] it like I enjoy
watching movies like maybe I can be kind
of good at making though I don't know
like so then I was started I did a
couple like short things as part of the
project and I realized oh I kind of like
that and so then going into high school
is like well I'm just gonna go in this
direction and then once somebody stops
me like I'll choose something nobody
stopped so cuz I I did some short feel I
was president of film Club in cop in
high school and I did something like I
did something like yeah yeah basically
just like all my friends it was just
like films oh but just my friends so he
made some shorts once some like awards a
like local like other high school film
festivals and stuff so it's like I guess
I'm kind of okay at this and so I just
kept going to that direction did you
ever do like any new segments new
segments yeah yeah like since you were
the president of the film Club like did
you guys have like an elephant
no that was handled by ASB so we didn't
really get to touch anything
no no
don't write no one we had a lot of sense
but no I mean we're just kind of like in
our own kind of world like doing our own
stuff but yeah but I just kept doing it
throughout college and then I just
blessed to like meet you know cool
people that continued to like encouraged
me and like push me in the direction of
like hey you could do this like we have
this like job here and stuff and working
at the other job that I work at Eva calm
like once I got my degree they're like
oh we got a film degree I make videos
for us doing that now yeah so but it's
all working out yeah do the class we met
in was dope let's go was Kevin O'Brien
what's that his name I think was a Brian
or so or was O'Brien a writer Zoomer
there's a really good subject of the
class it was it was a it was a hidden
class yeah it was worded weirdly it was
like the and now it was like the
analysis or practical application of
film or something like that no it was is
a dumb sound because which course
description was because also worth
Theory tracks there's not supposed to be
classes when you actually produce stuff
yeah it's supposed to be theory yeah one
of my biggest complaints about the long
beach film program in general just like
as a whole like was that very theory
based but yeah but we met in that class
and then he basically just gave us
because this dudes also a filmmaker and
he's also a professor at USC and he was
like just giving us a basically a crash
course to filmmaking he like explained
like craft services like food Johnson
stuff it was like a little bit
everything and then we produced our
little short things yeah in that class
and screened in those that was one of
the best classes that I took in home
whether your liver is like he taught us
about food yo no that's because nobody
nobody else did cuz like yeah I'll put
until that point nobody else told me
though is you got to keep it crew happy
yeah it's super important like yeah I'm
right you've been there for my craft
services
Kevin's craft service table I take very
nice I take his series that's how I
learned how to how to set up a craft
services table like the you have to or
you can't just throw the snacks on the
table you have to like organize it and
make it look appealing for people to
want to go know and like eat at it it's
really nice Devin do our craft services
know I'm down I love doing craft
services like calling the goal for craft
services is like you need to have to
where it's like people want to hang out
there but when they get called to set
they can grab and go like if you could
get people to get in trouble because
they're staying by your craft service
table you did a good job you did good
and especially we keep it under budget
because like you're pretty good at
staying in your budget oh I'm
I'm egotistical moment but I was good at
it alright you wanna change your pants
there I'm sorry it's like I had
flashbacks of a certain teacher who I
will not name I was thinking you're
gonna bring up this story Veneman every
funny of you just called him I'm really
tempted to but it cuz I don't think
there's any kind of issues of me naming
him but who knows cuz you know he's not
a working person
[Music]